don't let the vegas heat get the best of
your car findlay toyota the sponsors of
this next segment are here to get your
vehicle ready for summer
[Music]
one of the worst things that happened to
your vehicle is you drive in summertime
and boom all of a sudden your ac starts
blowing hot air
in vegas you're gonna melt within a
matter of seconds now the best fix to
that is to prevent it
all right now once you meet this tim
mcfadden he is with the finley toyota
service department how important is
preventive maintenance with the vehicle
yeah preventive maintenance for us is
the name of the game we don't have a lot
of mechanical breakdowns with the
toyotas as you know and our owners know
um so we want to stay ahead of the curve
if there's any mishaps that we can get
in the future we're going to go ahead
and do that it's not just toyotas that
you guys service do you guys service all
vehicles absolutely we have a lot of our
loyal owners that have been with us
forever that have other makes and models
you know in their garage at home they
like to come to us because they're used
to our service that we provide now
something like an ac goes out or you
guys are doing a preventative
maintenance looking at a vehicle you
find something wrong can you fix it
right on the spot most of the time we
can we have a very big parts department
with lots of stock of whatever parts
that we need if not we have options we
provide complementary uber service they
can get home
we have a rental car fleet where we can
rent them vehicles that way we keep them
on the road and you do have a
multi-point inspection that you guys do
with all the vehicles can you show me
that absolutely yeah let's take a look
perfect this is jesus one of findlay
toyota's top service technicians jesus
what are you guys looking for in your
multi-purpose safety is the number one
concern here at findlay toyota you want
to make sure that your customers
vehicles are safe to go down the road
you know for those road trips taking the
kids to school in this vegas heat we
don't want anybody broken down inside
the road so you're doing tires you're
doing brakes what about what's going on
underneath under under the vehicle under
the vehicle we have situations like most
customers wait for that oil leak to be a
puddle on the ground yes that's actually
not
the case on 90 of the vehicles you can
have oil leaks present like here without
having any evidence on the ground you
guys will catch this stuff ahead of time
get it fixed what do you do under the
hood under the hook let me show you all
right
so this is an engine what are we looking
for well we have one of the things that
we do is we top off all your fluids but
we do do an inspection there could be
oil leaks down here we have the battery
terminals that can have some corrosion
on them
and we have components like the radiator
for the cooling system of your vehicle
that may have cracks and something that
might not make it all the way down to
the bottom we're able to catch that from
doing under the hood inspections as well
this battery right here looking at this
just your eye on this battery is it okay
nice little corrosion there's a little
bit of corrosion there this would merit
a test a load test of the battery to
make sure that you're not going to be
stranded you know after coming out of
the grocery store and doing a terminal
cleaning of this is probably appropriate
for this vehicle this is something
everyone i think everyone have done with
the vehicle especially going to the hot
summer months this multi-point service
inspection catch the issue before it
happens when you're out driving right
yes absolutely you know it's the vegas
heat nobody wants to get caught waiting
for a tow truck waiting for a family
member to come pick them up and rescue
you so come to finley toyota get your
inspections done get service with us and
we'll treat you right i love it thank
you guys appreciate it absolutely thank
you thank you
thank you again to findlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment for more
information give them a call at
visit
702-566-2596
there's more las vegas now after this